burner num-nums
burden num noms our day Pardoner ah
therefore donor these are the lessons
for that skincare you cannot tell unless
hand sits it against alert having
lessons with attending care I don't even
know what I'm saying right now I know
that I'm the luckiest man in the world
tonight because I get to pay tribute to
a man who through his creative genius
has heaped joy upon the world Blake
Edwards had a profound effect on me
growing up after I saw a shot in the
dark which I really believe is the
perfect comedy I went through a long
Cato phase no one in my family was safe
I would attack with hot plumbing my
sister was thirty thirteen years older
than me and having sex with my
brother-in-law when I struck from the
foot of the bed
naked limbs flying everywhere saliva
she felt totally violated but it did
sharpen her senses the days of wine and
roses made us cry Breakfast at Tiffany's
made us fall in love and everything else
made us laugh like hell
ladies and gentlemen one of the true
masters Blake Edwards
this is happening
I help you out here come on buddy
there we go put your head down there
that's it that's it mom but you gotta go
watch my house I don't want to touch
your Oscar I just want to get you in the
podium okay
come on but now this is why they wanted
us to come in and rehearse yeah but
don't touch my eyes Oh
No
hold it
yeah I gotta hang on this up
let me have these man I know Mickey
holder might get it from you in a minute
King
I don't care anything Wow
that else good uh I've been allowed a
minute and a half of 90 seconds my
choice to thank everyone that made it
possible for me to receive this honor
when I started giving it some thought
serious thought everyone I mean everyone
I got me here tonight first person that
came to mind when I tried to pick them
out was a little guy who worked on the
party the film I did call the party and
he used to come out with a shovel and
scoop up the elephant poop and as he did
he sang there's no business like show
business
and then there was a confused Italian
actor that we tried to to get him to
understand what this okay sign meant in
our vernacular okay we just said just do
that and he always did this and so we
decided better we conform to him than he
to us so from then on ah on the set I
would say hey EV get the shot Phil uh
cutting Romy if you drop a couple of
frames just before the alligator
swallows the chimp Ralphie you think
Aubrey can sing it Henry
the point is each and every one who has
contributed to this moment friends and
foes alike yeah I couldn't have done it
without the foes I'm steamed and I'm
gonna prove you're wrong okay
so with everyone from the little guy
with the shovel to the discerning folks
in the Academy my mother thanks you my
father thanks you and the beautiful
English Broad with the incomparable
soprano and promiscuous vocabulary thank
you and I sure as hell thank you